I feel like Americans have this image of
us just bursting out into song and dance
in the middle of the railway station on
me2day basis Jiminy Cricket
look expired em this is incredibly
racist still running grocery stores
hindu store owner is not having ham in
his shop ham in an indian store does not
sell i don't know where you guys got
this who was the first Indian to go to
America who could have a major issue
with that guy he has stopped Indian
accents for everybody everyone on the
planet thinks that all Indians sound
like a bleep don't I will talk the rest
of the video like this I think you will
understand it and I like it even more
I like how colorful everything is
because that's what idea is right that's
not even an Indian dance yeah yeah that
is that is nothing like how we dance ah
this is how we done today I like it this
is normal palaces and for people yes
that is exactly what India comprises of
this incidentally how all of our
weddings look except that there are
about five times the number of people
here and food everywhere and less horses
is that true why is it at such a loser
yeah man it's it's for geeks and somehow
the Indian is is still the biggest like
loser in a lot of ways this is true
since most of the guys go abroad from
India engineers have Indian men ever
been show as shown in favorable light on
any Western show I can't recall a single
one of them why do we have to settle for
this all Indian men they're always like
sleazy you know can't hit it off with
women look at me man do you think I
can't hit it off with women it's
surprising the MT men Indian trees don't
stop for this long you're either on or
you're dead this is luxury for us there
is ample police at the station you
cannot just grab a girl and run away
like that I totally get why they're
showing this because it's a totally
realistic depiction of what happens
every day at CST notice how others don't
never does this guy really think he can
take on five goons on his own no one in
India would do a better you call your
own boys first I think what happens when
people try and put the cultures that
they don't understand in the media is
that they end up relying on stereotypes
in a country of 1.2 billion people right
a lot of us are really cool people maybe
should come down to India and we'll give
you a tutorial of what Indians are
really like we're not selling you or
Twinkie would you like to order
McDonough's vodka
No